[Musique]
l avis de ma mère depuis tout à l'heure
je suis comme un fou
chercher moi je trouve pas mon chien et
où je vais dans mon jardin je trouve pas
mon chien elle regarde et je le retrouve
ou ce dont
tu fais quoi ici
est ce que c'est normal c'est ta place
ici
ares pour hâter la
pourquoi tu es là
olala ça c'est des journées qui
commencent bizarrement
bonjour contre des tickets
vous savez que les animaux normalement
c'est dans les valises est amer et dans
les valises jean-marc un peu de respect
et ses contrôleurs il n'y a qu'à
contrôler ça sert à ça fonce en valeur
par contre les traits fins en retard
merci bonjour marc
bon c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait à
tarbes on
a tendance et à quelle heure on arrive
est-ce que sa main n'a pas ce qu'a fait
la g théâtrale m'interroger là et je me
disais peut-être j'approuvais m'énerver
quand même peut-être je peux dire mais
vous êtes un homme
[Musique]
pékin voit où on dit oui et c'est moi
mais c'est moi mais j'ai ma carte
d'identité regardez bien les mecs qui
vont adopter un beau monde se connaît
bien mais qu on marche on roule ensemble
bad dog pour la 10 mètres aux [ __ ]
famille - millau problème tu sens bon
mec
[Musique]
on